obviously a much bigger female presence
in infinity Wars this feels to be an
exciting time and a move in the right
direction how are you feeling about it
yeah it feels very good you know the
more ladies the better I always say you
know in the world so hey I have a
daughter who loves just absolutely love
seeing women kicking ass on the big
screen and I feel like that wouldn't
have happened 20 years 30 years ago
right like how long it's taken for that
to like be something we see so much more
predominantly and thank God we do
because you know it's done well we have
Captain Marvel coming up with I think
gonna be absolutely excellent she's
she's an incredible actor and it's been
it's it's been really exciting to see
and I also came on to it with only dude
it was just me and only dude that's
right it used to be you surrounded by
men all the time which must have been a
little bit of a strange experience for
you ah to supply all the estrogen on the
set you know right although they it was
Mark Ruffalo was there too
oh so repla is not here and he's taking
a beating yeah he also talks wonderfully
about his daughters and how they you
know love watching this sort of a thing
and it's really cool I mean the coolest
thing is that you know to see little
girls come up to us and talk about how
they love to like I was just totally
other they have this little girls trying
to like get some guns now and that's
like amazing cuz like there's so much
power and strength little girls have
that they're not always allowed to
express and I hope that the images
they're getting with Captain Marvel
coming out and and the work we've gotten
to do allows them to really start
feeling really fearless in their own
ferocity
you